et can exclusively announce that fifth  harmony is going on tour it's called the  727 tour in support of their upcoming  album 7/27 things kick off on July 27th  in New Hampshire the ladies have been  gushing about the album to ET all year  long  we're super stoked and we're really  excited 727 is a snippet of what's to  come for this new era 450 yeah  yeah  Stephanie from our past album reflection  I think we kind of took the time to for  ourselves throughout the past year and  so we kind of incorporated our  experiences gone through heartbreak  through love everything that's  everything the new tour is also helping  shutdown those breakup rumors that's  really our main focus in their first  love  so probably always been the foundation  regardless of everything that's been  going on that we've always always been  focused with harmony